il ya quelqu'un qui pour vrai était à
jeun depuis une minuit hier soir qu'il
s'attendait à soi face à chirurgie à
coeur ouvert aujourd'hui puisqu'elle
repose sa chirurgie à coeur ouvert parce
que parce que la ressource est occupée
puis la ressource est occupé en partie
par l'aco ville je veux rendez vous ce
matin pour une opération majeure
je veux rendre ici pour cela je me suis
aussi pour ça
j'ai attendu jusqu'à une heure jusqu'à
temps que ma vie ce que ç'avait été
cancellé
parce qu'on n'était pas en mesure de
mener l'opération
alors on à part depuis plusieurs jours
bonsoir josé chantal michel c moi je
reçois beaucoup de courrier les gens
disent mais sur quoi il n'ya presque pas
de spitz alisation pourquoi les
gouvernements ses nerfs d'abord elle
augmente
et puis il ya des conséquences réelles
docteur bellemare rôles à l'honnêteté de
le dire ce n'est pas que la coved le
système de santé étaient tirés mais
c'est aussi la coved parce qu'un sacré
coeur il ya eu trois malades sont
arrivés en soins intensifs coved et
savent ça reporter l'opération de
monsieur campagne je sais pas prévu mais
je veux je veux vous entends tour de
table là dessus
josée legault ça c'est sur le plancher
des vaches l'heure c'est sur le terrain
des hôpitaux la cc dans la vraie vie et
c'est pas une question de nombre c'est
une question de la forte possibilité que
ça aux morts je pense que tous les
experts et même le ministre de la santé
l'ont dit il faut s'attendre à une
hausse des hospitalisations à cause la
très haute contagiosité du baril à delta
et ce malgré la vaccination aujourd'hui
mylène drouin directrice de santé
publique à montréal l'avait entendu
comme moi elle a aussi averti qu' on
verra même des personnes double vacciner
finir à l'hôpital
donc ça va être une minorité mais ça va
quand même arriver ça c'est vraiment la
férocité du baril à delta donc oui on
ruse maj je pense qu'il faut montrer
cette réalité là mais pourquoi s'arrêter
justement au nombre immédiat il faut
projeter dans ce qui s'en vient
sipa les sur ma région
débat politique le jeu revient sur la
sphère politique chantal et michel
seydoux les débats politiques qui
commandons se sont passées fini qui
commence sur la vaccination obligatoire
dans tel secteur pourtant les employés
de l'état les conséquences et ce qu'on
les punisse qu on les punit pas le
passeport vaccinale c'est le début tout
chalon va falloir qu'on s'habitue à sion
chantal
sur la vaccination obligatoire et l'on
regarde seulement sur les deux dernières
semaines
c'est de plus en plus l'eau où on s'en
va dans de plus en plus d'endroits on
surveille dans le moment l'ontario par
exemple qui résiste à l'idée ne passe
pas au maximum selon moi cette
résistance le voit pas durer et une idée
qu'il va falloir être vaccinés et pas
seulement pour aller au restaurant ou
pour occuper des emplois au canada
aujourd'hui il tint conséquences vont
être est elle ne se soient pas routées
stone quelques fois par semaine
cette idée là inévitablement va gagner
du terrain au cours des prochaines
semaines celle ci
la pandémie n'est pas finie et quand on
dit on n'y a pas de mars pas trop grave
ce progrès il ya des problèmes dans les
hôpitaux il ya des problèmes dans tout
le système de santé qui sont causés par
l'afflux de patients que la pandémie
amen pique ça pas besoin d'être très
grand nombre pour causer des problèmes
on le sait que de toute façon notre
système de santé avant la pandémie était
à la corde alors c'est alors qu'un don
il faut pas non plus qu'on commence à
utiliser trop trop le vocabulaire retour
à la normale et c'est on n'est pas
encore au moment du retour à la normale
et il faut pas penser que le passeport
vaccinale des espèces de 2 sauf conduit
pour tout ça sera pas ça et ce sera pas
certain que cette vague ci ne sera pas
passée puis peut-être qu'on aurait une
honte après on ne sait pas
ok
oui à les échanger rapidement non mais
c'est ça et on oublie aussi que
d'enseigner là il ya des humeurs des
québécois et des québécoises comme
ailleurs qui vont peut-être survivre
mais qui vont rester avec la coved
l'homme qui vont inventer séquelles très
très très longtemps alors c'est ça joue
sur tous les tableaux et retour à la
normale mais celle ci je sais que c'est
fini je joue relance mais retour normal
non mais le passeport vaccinale c'est
une façon de cohabiter avec ça
normalement c'est une façon vous allez
aller au récent et que votre fils vous
allez chanter devant le restaurant que
son fils on va on va pouvoir sortir
c'est ça aussi l'idée qu'il propose et
je pense que si je pense que c'est
surtout pour convaincre ceux qui ne
veulent pas se faire avec 6000 jamais si
vous pouvez pas ignorer ce temps là si
vous n'avez pas les jours ça casse vous
pouvez pas vous allez avoir des
problèmes et je pense que c'est plus ça
que que le retour à la normale 1400
emplois soit gabut l'air le chocolat pas
trop vite c'est sur ok et justes et
jeûne en mangeant pour la même raison
quand justin trudeau dit vous pouvez pas
prendre un avion et un autobus s'est pas
seulement pour compter des points en
campagne électorale c'est pour motiver
les gens qui sont pas vaccinés à se
fabrique 6 très bien afghanistan la
porte s'est refermée
selon le vétéran transition' network que
sur les 400 familles et ça s'est
reconnue par le gouvernement aussi là à
quelque 400 familles qu'on visait qui
étaient dans des les abris dans des
maisons us où se cachait il y en a 70 ce
qu'on a pu faire entrer à l'aéroport qui
sont soit partis soit qu'ils sont en
sécurité à l'intérieur des murs leur ai
je vais faire entendre le message des
gens qu'il le reconnaît presque
clairement c'est pas mal fini et
monsieur trudeau et en revient
tout est possible
comme j'ai été très clair depuis le
début les talibans si les terroristes
nous n'allons pas aller nous n'avons pas
l'intention de les reconnaître nous
allons continuer de travailler pour
sauver le plus grand nombre de personnes
possible de l'afghanistan dans les jours
à venir mais aussi dans les mois à venir
alors l'analyse sera longue on peut pas
tirer de conclusions aujourd'hui mais ce
qui est à peu près certain ce qui est
certain c'est que le canada va laisser
derrière pas mal de monde qui ont aidé
le canada ça fait mal à beaucoup de
monde au canada dans les médias
anglophones je le disais hier je leur
souligner aujourd'hui c'est une histoire
qui est couverte avec beaucoup plus
d'ampleur que ici au québec le sitv news
ouvre avec ce tous les jours tous les
soirs dans les globe and mail toronto
star bref celle ci roger où vous en êtes
dans l'analyse politique de cette crise
là
deux choses d'abord effectivement
quelqu'un d'un poney ressources pour
sortir ces
bonis laissé sur place c'est tragique
mais c'est comme ça
donc c'est quand on regarde ce qui se
passe je regardais la télé française on
allait chercher des familles avec un
espèce de commando de
deux militaires français
cherchait eu les moyens de faire ça est
ce que c'est la faute du numéro parce
que c'est pas la faute de quoi ce je ne
sais pas je prends un expert militaire
mais la réalité c'est qu'avec le gadin
donne le port fait ça c'est une chose
l'autre chose c'est pour quand même se
rappeler que le fiasco
général qu'on voit là n'est pas le fait
du canada mais le fait de
l'administration américaine et que bon
et là on ça qu'une canada bread obligés
de partir beaucoup plus rapidement que
le 31 ou parce que le 31 août ça va être
les derniers américains qui vont sortir
qui vont fermer la place donc tous les
amis comme les autres vont faire pour
partir à faire c'est évident et encore
moins une chose qu'on peut sortir
beaucoup de jeunes
demain on va commencer à
sortir de leur stature que le dernier
avion qui pourrait ramener des gens qui
sont pas les soldats canadiens qui sont
là bas va probablement qui pays kaboul
demain et après ça ira pas plus loin est
ce que les libéraux se passerait de ce
genre d'une marge en campagne électorale
et est ce qu'on peut douter qu'ils ont
fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient pour
essayer de se tirer de ce pétrin en
campagne électorale je pense qu'on peut
pas douter il ya des gens qui disent
s'ils avaient pas eu de campagne
électorale on aurait fait différemment
j'aurais tendance à dire s'ils avaient
pas eu de campagne électorale peut-être
qu'on aurait fait moins bien mais sedan
grand portrait lors celui qui est pas la
campagne électorale et le 20 septembre
je suis curieuse de voir quel impact
cela va avoir sur les relations
canado-américaines parce que moi j'ai
l'impression que l'idée de cette grande
et bonne relation entre joe biden et
justin trudeau au vécu au cours des deux
dernières semaines on n'a pas
l'impression que les américains ont fait
grand chose pour tendre la main aux
canadiens c'est pas la première fois
depuis l'arrivée de ce nouveau président
américain mais pas un sport est de plus
en plus j'ai l'impression qu'il ya bien
des canadiens qui se tissent finalement
son principal mérite c'est pas être
donald joseph
c'est une tragédie sur plusieurs places
c'est évident et je pense que ça va être
à chaque électeur de poser son jugement
ou si on va au moins pendant les débats
comment le premier ministre se défend de
là dessus parce que on peut débattre de
la question on peut se demander si le
gouvernement trudeau a vraiment fait
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient faire dans la
mesure où ça soulève la question s'est
il préparé suffisamment et c'est pas moi
je ne suis pas une experte non plus
emphatique militaire mais je lis des
experts et il y en a plusieurs qui
soulève justement à cette question la
poste seulement envers le canada les
états-unis la france et c'est des gens
rendement exactement et que et que les
signes avant-coureurs est quand même là
on pourrait dire que c'est pas la
première fois que pays occidental ne
voit pas venir une crise mais un moment
donné il faut il faut quand même mais
voit revenir et là ça va être juste mais
ça va être soumis au jugement des
électeurs
très bien mais ça fera l'objet en tout
cas discussions lors des débats et des
entrevues
contourne aperçu très bien bon ce qui
m'amène à madame moncef qu'avez vous
pensé de cette de ce texte qu'elle a lu
jeudi un texte qu'elle a lu sur les
talibans l'appel aux talibans veulent
l'entendre on va entendre certains de
réaction et je vous entends est ce que
il ya une controverse où il y en a pas
selon vous on
est inédite ce pitch your
browser les talibans
oui cologne ou d'une chose de safe and
secure passage à begnins devait jouer en
afghanistan afp
le gouvernement trudeau a utilisé un
langage totalement
inacceptable après six mois d'inactivité
le gouvernement trudeau il y a des
milliers d'africains en danger à cause
de leur soutien de notre pays on a
besoin de leadership on a besoin d'un
plat
alors chantage commencé avec vous qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé du chat
aujourd'hui je remarque que monsieur
autour lui éviter d'utiliser le nom de
madame en chef est la raison pour
laquelle ils ont évité comme jack
meeting qui a dit moi je vais pas me
critiquer la ministre c'est parce que si
vous regardez sur les médias sociaux il
ya des gens qui se promènent dans la
prétendante également de sympathisants
qui est une réfugiée de parents afghans
qui ont fui l'afghanistan pendant le
conflit avec l'union soviétique et qui
est né on ira donc mal placé pour le
faire je suis pas convaincu que c'était
un bon choix de mots mais ça me semble
être une immense distraction de ce que
josé avec raison a qualifié de tragique
voilà
[Musique]
qui suis-je michel 5
dans un pays musulman ainsi que appeler
quelqu'un mon frère ma soeur c'est comme
normal c'est comme ça qu'on s'adresse
aux gens et là on faisait un terme à un
plaidoyer hôtel du var c'est déjà sortir
oui bonjour je suis tempête dans un
verre d'eau je dis dans la série qui est
allé voir les télés les talibans que cet
ancien avec eux aussi puis qu'il
plaidait aussi on passe sur scène au
joe's et legault rapidement là dessus je
parle du troisième lien
mais moi ce qui me dérange beaucoup à ce
qui s'est passé c'est que ce texte a été
écrit il a été écrit par des gens qui ne
semblait pas réalisé que la ministre par
les ponts en son nom personnel parce que
l'imminence elle parlait au nom du
gouvernement du canada et du
gouvernement du premier ministre aussi
justin trudeau elle a dit nos frères l'a
pas dit mais elle a dit nos frères et
nous vous demandons de faciliter
l'évacuation de l'afghanistan ces deux
nous là là c'est le nom du gouvernement
du canada et c'est peut-être pour ça
aussi que erreur ne tourne pas mentionné
le nom de madame en cfa mais plutôt le
nom mais plutôt à faire référent vous
savez vraiment et ça je pense que c'est
ok grave et ça nécessite un rectificatif
de la part du premier ministre plus
important que celui qui joue très bien
il françois blanchet en faveur du
troisième bien je fais écouter ça tout
de suite et on revient est ce que j'ai
envie de
faire la job du gouvernement du québec à
place du gouvernement du québec
clairement
on m'a demandé ce semblait de bonne
guerre on va voir ton avis personnel
après que je le donne il faudrait que la
campagne fédérale du bloc québécois qui
est un parti fédéral devienne une
campagne sur un enjeu du gouvernement du
québec je crois que le troisième y en a
un potentiel de contribution positive en
terme d'environnement notamment
pour éviter un nombre important de
véhicules faisant un important détour
chacun émettant des gaz à effet serre
sauf ceux qui sont électriques et il ya
un potentiel d'offre de transport
collectif entre deux centre-ville
économiquement très intégrée
alors chantal josé jeu c'est à votre
tour je commence avec vous un
projet environnemental d'une certaine
façon dit il c'est sûr bon
d accord sur cette question là mais
c'est là qu'on voit que le chef du bloc
québécois s'est piégé lui-même une
certaine manière dès l'élection de 2019
il a transformé le bloc oui leur
redonner un gros succès mais à
transformer le bloc en pigeons voyageurs
du gouvernement legault a donc c'est sûr
que dès qu'il ya un différend
dans sa propre base envers une politique
du gouvernement logo ça le met dans une
situation
et c'est j'imagine la raison pour
laquelle on a assisté aujourd'hui à de
l'acrobatie pas très belle et pas très
bonne à mon humble avis monsieur blanche
est aussi fait une distinction entre la
position son parti sa position
personnelle
c'est un moment donné ça devient
incompréhensible mais c'est ça donc
quand on sue est juste terminée là tu
sais que le bloc québécois semblent
avoir des difficultés à faire la
distinction entre les intérêts du québec
que qu'il est censé défendre et les
intérêts du gouvernement du québec quels
qu'ils soient qui soit caquistes
et là ça a été la suisse est au tout
pelure de banane ise vous n'étiez pas la
succursale de la cac mais celle ci n'est
pas disposé à 3
je suis d'accord avec ce que josé team
et je suis le goût mais messieurs
blanchet a toujours été un peu étrange
comme environnement tandis qu'at&t des
ministres de l'environnement du
gouvernement du québec c'est lui qui a
signé le décret auquel cimenterie
megueni selon le projet le plus
important pour faire des gaz à effet de
serre au québec ne soit pas souri à des
audiences du bape et aujourd'hui ils
s'en vantent encore c'est lui qui
trouvaient que les forages le dandy
consistait pas de mauvaises des puis ça
pouvait être fait de façon écologique
alors comme comme comme grant
environnementalistes on repassera il
reste que la réalité c'est que c'est un
débat qu'on peut faire dans une campagne
électorale fédérale parce que le
gouvernement du québec va de ma vie de
largeur et qu'à l'argent du public était
été piqué ça devient une question quand
on doit débattre puis l'a10 une question
de québec mais c'est tous les québécois
compagnie et le soulagement parce que la
part canadienne serait de 4 milliards
parle de beaucoup de sous quand même
chantal
et d'un côté le npd dont la position est
claire là dessus c'est non les
conservateurs surtout dans la région de
québec clés qui ont des sièges qui
doivent être dans la mire du bloc qui
disent nous on est prêt à payer donnez
nous la facture pour payer 40 %
c'était assez maladroit et en passant
monsieur blanchet est en politique
depuis trop longtemps pour penser qu'une
distinction entre son avis personnel et
la position de son parti et ce serait
comme de dire que justin trudeau premier
ministre du canada pourrait avoir des
opinions personnelles de son des
dossiers chauds qui serait différente
des politiques du gouvernement
donc il va mais il a il veut passer à
autre chose il va il va passer numéro
les libéraux c'est chaud comme ça la
saison verra monsieur le trou d'eau à
diochon verras ils vont nous présenter
leur trek on verra est ce que l'on verra
peut durer jusqu'au 30 jusqu'au 20
septembre michel
officiellement la position du
gouvernement c'était monsieur du culot
qu'ils l'avaient 2010 on pourrait
financer la partie transports en commun
mais on n'a aucun programme à ottawa
pour financer des autoroutes alors je
pense que cette citrouille le pot
répéter mais je pense que ça se tient
josy si la tentation était grande de
faire des gains au québec est-ce que
vous pensez que ça peut bouger d'ici la
fin du côté du gouvernement trudeau oui
du parti libéral geoff j'en serais
étonné je souhaitais gental ça bougera
pas jusqu'à renverser
il ya quelques sièges à québec et il ya
touché dans la région de montréal ou
troisième ligne un prêt franchement
c'est pas nécessairement bande à
josé et chantal michel fait merci
beaucoup à très bientôt au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit